after an infamously troubled production
and months of promotion and speculation
solo a Star Wars story has finally
arrived
it features crate action top-notch
special effects and a handful of
genuinely memorable performances still
it's far from perfect buckle up for
hyperspace so there are gonna be plenty
of spoilers ahead as we take a deep dive
into the five best and five worst things
about solo a Star Wars story best Lando
steals the show who didn't see this one
coming a lot of people have been excited
to see Donald Glover's debut as
legendary wheeler-dealer Lando
Calrissian
fortunately Clippers performance
delivers he's everything a young Lando
should be he's suave and talented yes
but also constantly posturing and
clearly insecure Glover is at his best
in solo and acting outlandos more
narcissistic tendencies and reveling in
his own fashion
I got an everyday cake sister's wedding
cape intergalactic Presidents Day cake
even nails the tone and inflection of
Lando's speech without ever doing an
outright impersonation bro in his
chemistry with his droid copilot l 337
and you've got a character who steals
every scene he's in worst lighten up
Solo has a couple of moments that are
very well framed but as a whole the
movie is a bear for visual letdown this
is particularly evident in the first act
which takes place mostly in seedy alleys
in crime dens these sequences are
terribly lit to the point that it's
nearly impossible to follow the action
there's a difference between dim
lighting and bad lighting it's not an
issue present throughout the entirety of
the film but it doesn't get much better
either there's some competence of the
cinematography but it never bowels or
feels as though it has purpose best ante
up the Star Wars saga is filled with
some of the most memorable action of all
time lightsaber duels and epic battle
sequences are the franchise's bread and
butter so it's interesting that the most
memorable scene in solo doesn't feature
so much as a blaster it's simply too
overinflated egos sitting across from
each other at a table and egging one
another on the moment han and Lando meet
for the first time immediately feels as
momentous as their Auto there's a
palpable tension as the two sides one
another up and once a card game begins
it cranks it in to light speed
when Lando finally lays down a force
aback and it feels like the final
crescendo of a symphony solos train
heists and the thrilling double crosses
in the finale can compare to Lando and
Han sitting down for a game of cards
worst dried and vast disappoints even
when the franchise is at its worst Star
Wars has a knack for great villains
we're not saying solar was the worst but
its primary antagonist crime boss Dryden
vast definitely isn't going into the
Hall of Fame anytime soon you can't help
but feel a little bored of the character
even without the knowledge that the
character was originally going to be a
half animal creature performed by
Michael K Williams have a mountain lion
half-human Paul Bettany is an immensely
talented actor and seems to be doing the
best he can with the material but a
swath of violent crime boss is nothing
we haven't seen in a hundred movies
before best old and Ehrenreich sticks
the landing it's not a stretch to say
that Hahn is one of the most beloved
movie characters of all time thanks in
no small part to Harrison Ford's
performance board is inseparable from
Han and Denny act death stepping into
the role has some big shoes to fill
despite those massive expectations
Ehrenreich does the seemingly impossible
in solo he makes you forget he's not
Harrison Ford Ehrenreich never seems to
be doing a Ford impression which would
have been an understandable approach to
the role instead he makes it his own his
heart is still witty and caustic but in
a way that feels like youthful bravado
rather than scorn he also gives hard and
ieave optimism that plays out
beautifully worst the first act
struggles solos troubled production is
common knowledge at this point and the
first act of the film is supported that
seems to have been the most affected by
the film's production issues and
reshoots various tones and moments are
struggling for dominance which is to be
expected from a movie with multiple
directors nothing about the first 20
minutes of the film really works and
it's largely because it doesn't seem to
have any sense of where it stands
once Han Chewie and Beckett board
fastest ship solo finds itself but it
takes longer than it should to get there
best world building solo is that its
most engaging when it's building the
criminal underworld of star wars crimson
dawn a syndicate of mob bosses who run
the shady a corners of the galaxy is an
immediately intriguing concept ripe for
further exploration and the fact that
the Alpha is headed by Darth Maul is
even better on top of that solos
introduction of emphasis and a cloud
riders a gang of renegade refugees is a
fantastic piece of new Star Wars law
these bits of expansion come in small
pieces but as a whole former very
engaging look at corners of this galaxy
we've never seen before
worst over-explain the way solo builds
on star wars are great but it also goes
out of its way to explain details
perhaps best left to the imagination the
most prominent example is the Kessel run
in which harden the crew make the run
only narrowly avoiding death by a giant
tentacle creature is awesome but finding
out what the Kessel run is to begin with
still feel somewhat unnecessary
similarly certain aspects of Hans
origins are inevitable like how he and
Chewbacca come together but did we
really need to know how he came into
possession of a signature blaster the
abundance of explanation that nobody
asked for in solos serves little purpose
and ultimately shrinks some of the
possibilities in its massive universe
first bringing it home you expect solo
to have a solid plot twist or two this
is a movie about criminals after all and
there's a major plot twists that moves
the final act into motion one that's
legitimately surprising and fists nests
and a cloud riders aren't smugglers at
all but refugees forming the first seeds
of what will become the Rebel Alliance
there's always a war to be fought in
these movies and solos seems like the
first installment in the franchise whose
focus is elsewhere and fists nest
reminds the protagonists of solo that
not only is there a war out there but
consciously or not they're playing a
part in it
without this solo is just a fun space
adventure whether it's a proper Star
Wars movie worst
it doesn't feel necessary when you get
right down to it han Solo never needed
an origin story he isn't a figure
shrouded in mystery like Boba Fett's
he's just a talented pilot who gets
himself wrapped up in a fight for the
fate of the galaxy everything a great
origin story needs is already present in
Hans arc in the original trilogy his
journey from cynical smuggler the true
believer in the noble cause of the
rebellion so why does this movie exist
that's ultimately solos biggest flaw it
fails to justify its own existence none
of this means you'll regret seeing it
but a no point does any of this become
anything truly special or answer the
question of why the Star Wars story
needed to be told
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]